she's doing good she's made me proud for
sure
MNN is one a super proud dad the 47 year
old rapper whose real name is Marshall
Mathers recently sat down with Mike
Tyson for an episode of the former boxer
podcast hot boxing and he opened up
about his 24 year old daughter Haley
both pet wolf at my kids boyfriends and
stuff yes baby she not babies nope just
um boyfriend yeah she's doing she's
she's she's doing good she's made me
proud for sure just graduated from
college 3.9 3.9 get it Haley
of course eminem shares Haley with his
ex wife Kim Scott Haley graduated with a
psychology degree from Michigan State in
2018 the rapper also reflected on how
much his daughter has grown during the
course of his career and how it's crazy
to listen to his old music that
references his little girl I have a
niece that I have helped raise too
that's kind of like a daughter pretty
much like a daughter to me and she is 26
and then I have a younger one that's 17
now so when I think about my
accomplishments like that's probably the
thing I'm the most proud of you know is
that he's being able to raise kids he
also explained that it was really
important that they be raised unaffected
by the fame money and privilege it's
definitely important to keep your kids
grounded when there's situations like we
have people also think to like money
just buys happiness and it absolutely is
not the truth you know I'm saying like
you gotta be right inside otherwise none
of it means nothing
[Applause]